[Music]
hi guys I'm hit Akutan eight years ago I
started as a beauty blogger I took a
leap of faith
and ended up starting my own makeup line
called for the beauty new huda beauty
products yes easy fake yeah we have
different tones and I think that's what
you know our whole concept behind baking
I love that you bake already yeah but a
lot of people don't know they don't they
don't they don't know how life-changing
it ahead it really is and you don't have
to do it where it's too much like it
there's exactly is a lot people don't
realize that you know and like you could
you could bake really hard for like I do
or you know even more or less way less
some days I'll just take a little powder
with my finger just kind of Pat it
autumn or dewy look yeah I don't what's
increasing underneath that that's what
it's about and so you know so this whole
concept easy-bake was really to make
make it easy
don't press I'm proud of what you've
been able to do in five years it's
incredible and the quality and the
innovation yeah and it's you're just
you're killing it what do you think
about collaborating I know in one of the
episodes to face yeah baby collaborating
with yes but we're trying to get that
done and I respect Jared and Jeremy so
much for what they've done and you know
to be honest like she faced honestly is
one of my favorite beauty brands yeah
they're kind of doing I feel like so
much right now there's no innovative so
cool many different so exciting I really
excited to cover it with them what would
you want maybe a pallet yeah I we're
trying to maybe work out a pub we're
gonna see that so that's kind of what we
talked to them but like Rihanna would
you ever wanted or Kim or yes I mean be
like who would be your dream
besides to face to collab with Opie on
say she is just the Queen and I just
like think you're two million things
with her I'm obsessed with her and she
sometimes yeah she gives women strength
you know when you think about like all
the BS that everybody goes through and
you're like well then you can't you
could be focus on that or you could be
Beyonce yeah cuz that's
I want some of your beauty tips and sure
I don't think anything we need that what
are some tips you would give to put on
flawless I think start light you know I
think a lot of people when they're
starting with makeup they just want to
go overkill and do a lot and I think
sometimes doing less is actually so much
better I just thought my team was
editing a video and it was a cool video
is a hack and it was one my favourite
hacks that I've ever done and it was
with and I shouldn't be telling people
not to wear false lashes but yeah they
went so well it was basically put
mascara that you take like cotton and
you put cotton on your lashes and then
you put more mystery but car then you
put where am I scared it it actually
worked it all never hurt it gives you
like extension it's amazing
Oh or if you want to wear false lashes
just cut them up yeah that's what people
don't realize yeah you have to measure
you're like how do you life it's all
know everybody's eyelid is like a
different shape and differently what are
some rookie mistakes you see women
making when it comes to beauty I
definitely feel like it's so funny
because I got like dragged for saying
this once but I still hold this true I
think that lighting is so important when
you're getting ready because like
especially if you're if you're a rookie
and you want to go for like a heavier
look yeah I think lighting is key and
you don't want to go somewhere that's
over let you don't wanna go somewhere
it's like you know sit in front of
mirror in front of a window is great
I think everybody's had that where
they've contour too much and they go
here like wow you know I look just on
your ge yeah I feel like your nose is so
drawn around you know so I definitely
think lighting is really important I
will never like that to me like when I
was doing makeup as a megabyte
I just always bring my own lighting like
to me it's so important and I think that
you could definitely avoid some mishaps
with good lighting
you
[Music]